il était une fois le kansas coin de pays
connu pour ses plaines son agriculture
et son ciel imposant
un royaume rouge qui vote républicain
depuis presque la nuit des temps et où
se déroule un conte de fées mondialement
connu le magicien d'oz
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire de la jeune dorothée
dont la maison est emporté par une
tornade vers le pays merveilleux doses
où se trouve la route des pavés jaune
qui mène au bonheur sous le regard du
magicien
[Musique]
il y atteler à 18 ans presque comme un
conte de fée pour la première fois de sa
vie elle va voter dans son kansas rural
conservateur elle a décidé de donner un
coup de main à une candidate démocrate
pour gagner un siège au sénat occupée
par les républicains depuis 88 ans une
trentaine de curieux ont bravé le froid
pour écouter la candidate de ali en ce
matin parmi eux
ses parents et ses deux grand-mères qui
sont plutôt divisées par la politique
[Musique]
pendant que la jeune démocrate continue
son travail de campagne politique
nous retrouvons ses parents dans leur
entreprise familiale de carrosserie ici
on répare ce qui est abîmée et il
aimerait bien pouvoir faire la même
chose avec washington
autour d'un café la petite famille n'est
pas peu fier de la plus jeune qui
s'engage en politique
mais ce n'est pas le cas de sa mère
pourtant aussi républicaine quant à la
mère de amy elle votera démocrate
se pourrait-il que le kansas très rouge
vire un peu plus vers le but
et deviennent violet pas si vite et très
fort
pas étonnant que ninja gaiden ni donald
trump ne soit donc venu dans cet état
mais quelque chose bouge un peu en cette
terre si républicaine un boom pour notre
famille qui on a assez que le kansas
soit tenu pour acquis ses droits comme
dorothée qui se réveille au kansas dont
le magicien d'oz au fait saviez-vous que
ce fameux comptes publié en 1900 a été
interprété comme une allégorie politique
sur les états unis
et si on l'adapté à 2020
[Musique]
[Rires]
oublié par washington le pays d'oz du
kansas
sans souffle et non pas une tornade
bleue mais peut-être un peu le vent du
changement ali se lancera t
peut-être un jour en politique ça c'est
une autre histoire
[Musique]